[Music]
hi thank you for joining us today in our
session about DDOS defense with Google
Cloud armor today we'll tell you about
how Cloud armor protected A customer
from the largest application Level
distributed denial of service or DDOS
attack reported to date as well as
deliver practical guidance on how to
minimize risk in your own environment
my name is Emil kiner and I'm the
product lead for cloud armor here at
Google Cloud
hi I am Satya konduru I'm the technical
lead for cloud rocker
today we'll start with a quick overview
of cloud armor before jumping into
details and Analysis of the 46 million
requests per second attack we recently
disclosed after that we'll share
practical guidance on how you can assess
and mitigate DDOS and web risk on
internet-facing web applications and
services
we'll conclude with a few updates about
recently launched features and
capabilities to help you protect your
applications
Cloud armor is the DDOS mitigation
service and web application firewall on
Google Cloud we are able to protect your
web applications and apis from all
manner of DDOS threads including layer 3
4 Network and volumetric protocol-based
attacks as well as layer 7 floods while
also functioning as a web application
firewall to detect and mitigate
web-based threats like the OS top 10 web
app vulnerability risks or enforce
custom layer 7 filtering policies Cloud
Armor's protection against layer 3 4
volumetric and protocol-based attacks is
always on when you deploy one of our
Global load balancing proxies users can
configure security policies to further
filter incoming requests based on
attribute spanning layers three through
seven using our custom rules language or
leverage our pre-configured wac rules or
deploy our machine learning based
adaptive protection capability to
automatically detect and mitigate
attacks Cloud armor is deployed at the
edge of Google's Network where it has
the opportunity to inspect requests and
enforce policies Upstream of customer
workloads so we can drop unwelcome
traffic before it has a chance to impact
your applications and networks all of
Google's Edge infrastructure stack
including Cloud armor the load balancers
and CDM can be deployed Upstream of
applications wherever they reside in
addition to being able to protect
workloads on gcp you can leverage
Google's investment in Edge capacity by
deploying Cloud armor in conjunction
with our load balancers in front of
applications on your premises or within
another infrastructure or cloud provider
Cloud armor is built on the same
hardware and software stack that Google
has developed to protect our own billion
user properties as a result the full
scope and capacity of our Global Network
can be brought to bear to protect your
applications at planetary scale we
recently announced that we have
protected A gcp customer from the
largest DDOS attack reported to date at
46 million requests per second a few
years ago we announced that we had also
protected against a 2.54 terabit
volumetric attack also holding the
record for that attack type until
earlier this year in any case this is
made possible because we provision
enough capacity at the edge of our
Network in order to be able to absorb
high volume attacks
we continue to see exponential growth
and attack sizes into the foreseeable
future and are continuing to invest in
our Network scale and capacity in order
to be able to protect our customers and
their applications to ensure those
Services remain available and reliable
now I'll dive into the details of that
Peak attack you saw in my previous graph
generally what happened was a long time
customer was targeted with the largest
layer 7 DDOS attack reported to date at
46 million requests per second
fortunately the attack failed and
seriously impacting the customer's
application because they were already
running adaptive protection which
allowed us to notify them of a growing
attack early and empowering the customer
to rapidly take action by the time the
attack ramped up to its peak the
customer had already deployed the
Adaptive protection recommended rule
allowing us to step in and block an
overwhelming majority of the unwelcome
traffic
to give you a sense of how quick these
things happen I'll walk you through a
rough timeline
at 9 44 a.m Pacific time the attack
started at roughly 10 000 requests per
second
over the next nine minutes it ramped to
about a hundred thousand requests per
second triggering adaptive protection to
detect and generate an alert
after a brief period of triaging the
situation and validating Cloud Armor's
recommended rule the customer deployed a
rate limiting rule to detect and
throttle based on the Adaptive
protection suggested signature
shortly thereafter the attack began to
ramp up to its 46 million Peak and since
the customer already deployed our
suggested rule Claude armor was able to
drop most defending requests and help
ensure that customer's application
remained available
over the next half hour the attack
ramped down ultimately concluding at 10
54 a.m only 70 minutes after it started
our research showed that over 5200
Source IPS all representing compromised
devices participated in the attack to
deliver absolutely observed request
volume
more than a fifth of the source IPS are
associated with Tor exit nodes which
contributed roughly three percent of the
total attack request volume
that three percent from Tor corresponds
to well over 1.3 million requests per
second which on its own could probably
take down all but the largest web apps
and services out there the attack was
distributed globally with Source IPS
originating from 132 countries four
countries were the source of over 30
percent of the attack traffic
more than 75 percent of the compromised
devices came from just 22 of the 132
countries based on all the
characteristics we were able to observe
we assessed that this attack came from
the Marist botnet matching many elements
that our industry Partners have written
about over the past year the Maris
botnet has been reported to consist of
at least 200 000 devices in which case
the 5256 devices generating the 46
million RPS Peak represents just 2.5
percent of the potential strength of the
spot net in addition to expecting attack
sizes to continue their exponential
growth we think an even larger
application Level attack is possible
today
and now I will hand it off to Satya who
will tell you more about the details of
how the attack was detected and
mitigated as well as provide mitigation
guidance that you can use to plan for
your current or future web application
deployments
thank you amen in the attack that Emil
just mentioned adapter correction
detected an initial spike in the volume
of attack traffic compared to the
Baseline although the attack sources are
spread across many countries and contain
varied L7 attributes adaptive protection
was able to generate an attack signature
with high confidence which implies
negligible impact to Baseline traffic
Cloud armor then alerted the customer
with the attack details and suggested a
rule to deploy
customer then deployed the suggested
meditation as a rule with a rate limit
action it was first put in preview mode
to study its impact once it's all clear
customer activated the role the
activated rule prevented a much larger
attack of 46 million plus per second
from impacting that ends
next I am going to talk about the
threats that cloud services face in the
form of DDOS and peppers and then
provide deep guidance on mitigation
using Cloud armor being ready for dros
threats starts with early planning we
recommend that you do a comprehensive
threat modeling of your cloud services
where first identifying all the attack
surfaces and then identify threats to
those suspect surfaces it includes
tracking new DDOS attack types and
understanding the impact of those
threads Next Step involves defining a
strategy with prior to mitigations which
I will cover shortly and finally being
able to monitor for those threats on
that path of mitigations
planning also includes capacity planning
you should understand the Baseline
traffic and make sure the service is not
run at capacity you should plan to
absorb low unexpected spikes by or
provisioning your service or better
enable auto selling so gcp can help
increase capacity on a need basis
a separate capacity planning exercise is
recommended for special events like
limited time offer retail events and new
product launches
in this section I want to touch upon
certain prior to mitigation strategies
that can be put in place to counter the
threats from DDOS and fabrics these fall
into three categories to mitigate DDOS
risk you should deploy rate limit
actions against abusive clients you can
also use threatened intelligence to
limit traffic volumes from known bad
sources like power exit nodes
Additionally you can also rate limit or
filter traffic from regions outside the
target markets committee at barter is
you can deploy recapture to detected
parts and in high volumes of traffic and
consider rate limiting the bot traffic
or redirect into honeypots
to mitigate web attacks we recommend
deploying pre-configured bath rules for
various OS top 10 mutations a more
comprehensive protection involves
deploying Cloud armor along with apigee
Gateway for APA protection finally I
will be covering the incident response
in the event of an attack
the response handling falls into four
steps the instance response should
reduct on an alert that is already set
up for spiking and attack findings from
cloud armor via the security Command
Center
second step is to trash the attack alert
you should assess the impact of the
attack on the suggested mitigation rule
third step is to validate the impact of
the rule in preview mode either with a
blocking action or a rate limit
detection the final step is to deploy
the mitigation by turning off the
preview mode this concludes our
recommendations and we hope that the
displaced strategies along with the
tools available in cloudapper will help
you effectively manage the DDOS and
beverage for your gcp services
now back to Emil who will talk about
what's new in Cloud
thanks
Cloud owner adapter protection has been
in GA with significant customer adoption
in their production workloads
adapter protection establishes a
baseline of traffic patterns on a per
application basis and will detect an
alert on potential attacks it will also
calculate a signature of the attack
traffic and include that in the
generated alert both in a user-readable
form as well as a proposed Cloud armor
WAFF rule to deploy to mitigate the
attack in real time
today we are announcing the preview
release of the auto deploy feature in
adaptive protection that can
automatically detect and mitigate an
attack
you can attach any action to the auto
deploy rule including blocking rate
limiting or redirect as always we
recommend putting the rule in preview
mode first the auto deploy capability
also lets you control when a mitigation
is deployed based on user configurable
thresholds across traffic volume load or
attack confidence in order to trigger
the auto deploy
in addition to Adaptive protection Auto
to play we have introduced several
expansions to our rules language and
rules engine to help protect customers
first we have just made generally
available the 3.3 version of our
pre-configured Waf rules corresponding
to the most recent version of the
industry standard set of rules to help
mitigate the OAS top 10 web app
vulnerability risks as well as meet your
security and compliance requirements
next we have just made our Waf rules
easier to deploy and maintain through
the preview release of advanced rule
tuning this allows customers to easily
dial in the sensitivity or granular
tuning preferences for their Waf rules
this includes the ability to exclude
individual request elements like headers
or cookies from inspection to reduce
noise as well as an ability to
explicitly opt into desired sub
signatures of the rules
as part of this release we have also
expanded our API protection abilities
through expanded support for Json
formatted requests for any configurable
content type
lastly we continue to expand our custom
rules language with more functions and
transformations in response to customer
demand we are also excited to announce
the general availability of our new
Google Cloud threat intelligence
platform the new platform combines
threat Intel from Google's various
security teams third-party Partners as
well as open sources and delivers them
as easy to use feed categories such as
bad reputation IPS to our exit nodes or
public Cloud IPS which can be consumed
by a growing set of enforcement points
across Google Cloud threat Intel support
in Cloud armor is generally available
today while thread Intel for cloud
firewall is coming as a preview soon
over time threat intelligence feeds will
be available for use across more
enforcement points and new products
across Google Cloud
Cloud armor and the recently announced
Advanced API security offering in the
apogee API management platform work
together to help organizations protect
their applications and apis advanced API
security is a comprehensive set of
capabilities that enable organizations
to more easily mitigate two risk factors
bot attacks because of the increasing
volume of API traffic there's also an
increase in cyber crime in the form of
API bot attacks Advanced API security
provides API teams an easier way to
identify malicious Bots within API
traffic and speeds up the process of
identifying data breaches
misconfigured apis are one of the
leading reasons for API security
incidents to help identify apis that are
misconfigured or experiencing abuse
Advanced API security continuously
assesses all managed apis and provides
app teams with a recommended action when
configuration issues are detected
lastly in case you missed some recent
announcements earlier in the year we
recently announced expanded Cloud armor
coverage to protect more workload types
by introducing support for the TCP and
SSL proxy load balancers as well as
launching Edge security policies to
protect CDN and GCS workloads we have
expanded our detection and mitigation
capabilities introducing the ability to
detect and stop bot threats with bot
management featuring a deep integration
with recaptcha Enterprise as well as the
ability to enforce per client rate
limits which was leveraged to stop the
attack we talked about earlier
all of these new expansions and
capabilities are generally available the
last update we're excited to share is
that as a result of all of the recent
developments we have shared with you
today Forester has named Google Cloud
armor a strong performer in the most
recent Forester way for web application
firewalls this was Cloud Armor's initial
debut on the wave and it serves as a
strong third-party validation of and
testament 2 our ability to protect
customer applications from all the risks
we talked about today at planetary scale
I'd like to thank Satya for helping me
show you that with Google cloud and
Cloud armor you are able to quickly and
easily protect your internet-facing
workloads providing you the Peace of
Mind necessary to allow you to focus on
operating your own mission critical
applications
you can get started with Cloud armor
today by navigating to it in your Google
Cloud console under network security and
begin configuring security policies
if you're interested in learning more
about latest developments across the
network security product portfolio on
Google Cloud check out the sessions
listed here
thank you for joining us today and enjoy
the rest of next 22.
[Music]